ce n'est pas un signe de bonne santé
mentale que d'être adapté à une société
malade
gide ou chris martin est ce que ça vous
arrive vous opposer une des questions
dix ans est ce que la vie que j'étais en
train de mener présentement est ce que
l'absence est ce que ma façon de vivre
la vie en ce moment a vraiment un sens
et s'ils avaient un autre façon de vivre
la vie pour pouvoir me réaliser
pleinement ici oui ici même lorsque
grange la villa moi j'étais un grand
rêveur je suis de ceux et celles qui ont
envie de vivre différemment qui ont
envie de mettre un sens dans cette vidéo
mais pour ça je dis pas se passer par un
chemin pas toujours facile
j'ai eu le privilège fantastique
exceptionnel le environ 11 ans de faire
un magnifique brune qui s'y est déjà eu
ce privilège la hoya une bonne mais la
grosse faim pour ces gens-là génial
génial
sans cette période que j'appelle de
contraction la cette période de
résistance cette période de doute cette
période où est-ce qu'on est complètement
perdue jamais j'aurais pu ici devant
vous à terre d'aujourd'hui mais en même
temps en cours de route je me suis
énormément poser de questions il y avait
un autre façon de vivre la vie c'est pas
un signe de bonne santé mentale que
d'être adapté à une société malade
aujourd'hui je me spécialise en
enseignement de pleine conscience j'aide
les gens à calmer leur mental à
reconnecter avec ce qui est là interdite
oui en dit long non avec cette partie
divine qui colle à l'intérieur de chacun
d'entre nous cette partie où est-ce que
tout est toujours parfait tout est
aligné et pour ça pour réapprendre à
vivre d'une certaine façon
pour seule frayeur et apprendre à calmer
ce mental là pour revenir ici moment
présent qu'est ce qui fait qu'on souvent
de la perception d'être complètement
perdu 1
on est pris dans la connaissance on le
voit on cherche toujours à avoir
davantage de connaissances on met notre
attention sur ce qui nous manque dans la
vie est deux on sait pas quand mâcon
fonctions on ignore le fonctionnement
de la machine humaine personnellement
j'ai pas eu des parents qui ont pu
m'apprendre soit pourquoi parce qu'ils
savaient pas où mais à l'école on
l'apprenait pas quand j'étais plus jeune
mais c'est en train de devenir de plus
en plus accessible avec des conférences
comme celle là mais en fait comment
fonctionne la machine humaine
comment arriver à calmer notre esprit
comment arriver à se réaliser pleinement
à profiter notre grand jeu de la villa
en activant notre véritable potentiel en
ayant dépensé bio est ce que vos pensées
sont bio
aujourd'hui ce qu'il sujet que je vais
vous apporter parce que pour pouvoir se
réaliser pleinement voir ces fameuses
étoiles dans les yeux ce sentiment
d'ouverture lors profiter de notre
voyage ici on doit avoir des pensées
cohérente aligné avec notre idéal de vie
cohérente aligné avec les valeurs qu'on
porte à l'intérieur de nous à chaque
instant dépenses et cohérent et aligné
avec ses grandes vérités universelles
si vous êtes de ceux et celles qui se
sont déjà posés la question ici avait
quelque chose d'eau et si j'étais plus
grand que ça s'il y avait une puissance
qui était plus grande que ce que je
porte et moi je vous assure que cette
puissance aux halles existe quand j'ai
eu le privilège fantastique de faire une
dépression en berne
s'ensuivit une séparation la vente d'une
entreprise la saisit finalement le la
faillite est quelque part en fait
j'étais littéralement perdu aujourd'hui
je peux vous garantir c'est une des plus
belles choses qui s'est passé dans ma
vie mais par contre j'ai dû réapprendre
à fonctionner réapprend à vivre
j'ai eu le privilège fantastique de
tomber sur des enseignements qu'on
appelle vipassana qui connaît les
enseignements du passé n'en gold les
enseignements du passé ne sais quoi
pendant une dizaine de jours n'est pas
en retrait en train de méditer à
observer ton esprit vaudois parlait pas
droit de lire padois décret est juste
toi par rapport à toi observé ton esprit
un souvent ici pas de bouder le christ
nager au vote en côtoyant tort rien tout
ça toi par rapport à toi main cette
expérience de vie l'ont littéralement
transformé ma vie pourquoi parce que
j'ai appris à maîtriser la machine et
surtout calmer ma machine
j'étais quelqu'un qui était totalement
dispersés dans la vie j'ai quelqu'un qui
faisaient de l'anxiété
c'est toujours dans la paix
forme ans vous savez cette performance
la 81 85 % des gens dans notre société
son prix du partant de la performance si
on est pris de ce fameux patin de la
performance là on est pris dans notre
insécurité les plus performants de notre
société sont les gens les plus vains
figure et on s'en réjouit pas con
aujourd'hui c'est mon expertise j'arrive
à comprendre comment fonctionne
exactement le processus mais il a
personne qui va être temps d'en être
dans la performance
c'est la personne qui va commencer à se
juger à se critiquer je sais qu'on n'a
pas dans la salle ici à se culpabiliser
a surtout sa beauté elle se met en doute
manque de confiance un moment donné les
plus fonctionnels du tout et jésus ainsi
baisse 10 le stade il faut qu'on
recommence et on recommence à performer
on cherche que tout soit parfait
toutefois comme on dit ici sur la coche
il est français et u10 au top on cherche
à performer que tout soit parfait
on est souvent dans le futur en train de
tout planifier structure et appréhender
la haute saône en grand sage viège
d'apprendre la langue pour enseigner
sites à tendance et dans le futur c'est
parce que tu as tendance à faire de
l'anxiété
cette tendance est dans le passé ce que
tu as tendance à être dépressif et si tu
as tendance à être ici au moment présent
parce que tu as tendance à être en paix
la plus grande clic j'ai ramassé en
cours de route lors des expériences de
méditation qui aujourd'hui fait plus de
13 fois je sais retraite de méditation
vipassana aujourd'hui ce que j'enseigne
vivent les près d'une cinquantaine de
fois ce sur quoi tu mets ton attention
prend de l'expansion
aujourd'hui mon mentor c'est la nature
tout est déjà là dans la nature on doit
réapprendre à connecter avec qik on est
vraiment une fois qu'on connecte avec
qui connait vraiment on va apprendre à
s'observer pour apprendre à s'observer
on va développer ce qu'on appelle la
vigilance
et quand je vais dijon je vais arriver à
observer chacune de mes pensées à ce
moment là mes pensées vont être alignés
et cohérent donc mes pensées vont être
bio
mais dans la vie de tous les jours est
ce que nos pensées sont véritablement
bio l'arrêt décès que non bio c'est tout
libéré de tout être tout environnement
toxique mais nous notre passé revient
constamment ce qui pourrait l'être mon
passé pour élèves mon ex que les progrès
dans la patiente alimentaire les dit que
je traîne donc notre parti revient
constamment s'ils le pensent et revient
ce à cause des pressions si j'ai mon
attention dans le passé ça cause de
pression mais ce qui met pensées sont
constamment dans le futur je vais
chercher à contrôler appréhender
structurés à ce que ça aille trop vite
je vais être impatient ce qui vaut ce
tricycle l'opposé stress angoisse
anxiété qu'ici aux tendances en page
stress et angoisse anxiété lever la main
du poids de bandes m'avait de réponse
est de souk et c'est parfait ça fait
partie de la vie ce qu'on doit apprendre
ça reprendre la maîtrise de celui-ci de
cette attention là de revenir ici au
moment présent ce que la réalité est
toujours ici dans l'instant présent
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure pour
pouvoir se réaliser pleinement on doit
apprendre à vivre en cohérence avec les
valeurs que l'on porte
avec ses grandes vérités de l'universel
et bien en cohérence avec nos
convictions profondes quels sont vos
convictions profondes
est ce que vous laissez tomber ça si
vous écoutez pas les valeurs qu'ils
vivent ce qui vous met des étoiles dans
les yeux
votre la chine voit s'agiter dont vous
serez pas que vous serez plus cohérent
vos pensées vont être désordonnée
complètement si vous n'écoutez pas vos
convictions profondes
ce que vous pensez que c'est vraiment la
vie vous allez devenir ajouter aussi
voir un manque de cohérence donc
complètement dans le passé dans le futur
si j'apprends pas écouté ma machine
mon corps ils vont crier davantage plus
forts doivent apprendre à développer mon
focus qui cite enquêtait jeunes ont déjà
pris une loupe comme ça allait d'or à
l'extérieur et faire brûler une
grenouille non non non non une feuille
de papier oui qui est déjà fait soeur ou
une feuille exact maintenant essayer
aujourd'hui de prendre la même loupé et
de faire brûler une feuille de papier en
faisant ça comme ça ici est ce que c'est
possible
pas du tout pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas
d'attention et la tension et la tri
de tout si je n'ai pas d'attention je
n'arrivais jamais à voir du résultat
jamais jamais jamais je dois pas en art
saisi cette attention la fois développer
ma concentration doit apprendre à saisir
cette attention là pour revenir sur
moment présent parce que vous savez quoi
au moment présent
pendant tout le monde regarde ici il
nous manque absolument
on est complet dans l'instant présent
mais quand je suis dans le futur dans le
passé jusqu'à agiter ou jetés en
incohérence parce que je veux faire les
choses dans la performance
il me manque quelque chose je me promène
dans la vie avec ce sentiment de mon
oncle et pourtant
j'arrive ici et je suis complet on doit
vivre avec sévérité le qui s'passe
intérieures de notre nation
le stress l'angoissé l'anxiété a sa
raison d'être
dernière manche forme chantent des
chants des chorales à peine conscience
j'ai un prof dans monde en mai qu'au sur
21 sur 23 élèves dans cette classe 21
élèves et médicamenté ça n'a juste aucun
bon sens je lis un article dans le
journal de montréal environ trois mois
ici 63 % d'augmentation
d'antidépresseurs c'est les aînés ça le
juste
aucun bon sens se gagne aucun bon sens
mais en même temps qu'ils s'y soient y
en ait soyez très honnête qu'ici dans
les buts dans le dernier mois est arrivé
au moins une fois à la maison avec
l'impression d'avoir j'ai l'esprit
complètement saturé lever la main génial
regardez autour de vous on arrive à la
maison sans complètement saturé le trou
d'information qui rentre dans notre
plainte
comprenez bien une chose il rend plus
d'informations dans notre tête en une
journée aujourd'hui qui a rentré en 1
année vélo sans tain et l'avenir
appartient pas à ceux et celles qui sont
les plus talentueux les gens les plus
intelligents
l'avenir appartient à ceux et celles qui
vont être le plus vigilant qui vont
s'observer qui vont observer qu'en qui
viennent pour passer ici à ted et que
eux en fait nous ont rien de monter un
des gens qui ont ce sont structures qui
ont pas nécessairement d'instruction qui
ont envie d'être dans le flou comme moi
aujourd'hui
d'embarquer dans un événement comme sap
qui se dira atteint peut peut-être que
je me prend trop au sérieux
est-ce que je perds vite peut être tout
simplement présents selon mes
convictions
que comprendre que de toute façon
l'information proférées par coulis de
comprendre que peut-être c'est le temps
de lâcher mon travail parce que je le
sens les terres de moins dont notre
intuition nous parle à chaque instant
mais pour être capable d'écouter notre
machine capable de commencer à vivre en
cohérence avec la vie je dois d'abord et
avant tout revenir ici au point note
dans l'instant présent chaque
contraction chaque moment
d'insatisfaction chaque moment dans
notre vie qui vaut pas comme on veut
nous ramène et conspire à nous ramener à
la reconnexion de qui nous sommes
vraiment tout est déjà là à l'intérieur
de nous faut je serai après on a utilisé
le potentiel qu'on a et surtout ramener
cette attention là parce que si je rends
même pas mon attention dans l'instant
présent je vais toujours appréhendé ce
qui va se passer avant de passer sur la
scène ici tout à l'heure je me suis pas
dit mais les goûts très très bon
conférences et je me suis je me disais
tout simplement calmes toi qu'un poids
comme toi même toit vous avez
probablement vu quand j'ai commencé à
donner la conférence je suis venu la
bouche très très très très porteuse jeu
m'observait et je me disais ok calmes
toi calmes toi calmes toi c'est dans
l'expérience directe qu'on doit
apprendre à se maîtriser ces points sur
papier c'est pas dans un livre de la
connaissance
on doit arriver à intégrer tous au et
moi j'aimerais profiter du temps que
j'ai ici à ted pour faire vivre une
expérience fantastique qui que le goût
de vivre une expérience fantastique
lever la main génial on va prendre 90
secondes
écoutez bien ça je vais vous faire
respirer de texter génial regardez bien
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant les 90
prochaines secondes à chaque expiration
vous aller respirer à votre rythme à
chaque expiration pendant les 90
prochaines secondes à l'expiration vous
allez faire
à l'intérieur deux bouts moi je vois
d'être calmes forme et vous allez le
dire à l'intérieur de vous mais souffre
d'un langage hypnotique et observer ce
qui se passe dans votre machine
ok on s'installe c'est parti on espère
tout doucement public en délire revenu
avec moi ici probablement plusieurs
parmi vous ont ressenti automatiquement
dans leur corps les épaules se déposer
un meilleur focus vos sens se sont
aiguisés une meilleure présence ici
meilleure concentration et pourtant en
seulement 90 secondes
l'outil le plus puissant qui soit pour
se libérer du stress de langoat
l'anxiété des auc débat de la vie c'est
de reprendre la maîtrise de notre
machine la maîtrise de notre attention
de revenir ici dans l'instant présent
pourquoi chercher des trucs
extraordinaires pour chercher tout ce
qui est accessible
l'être humain est parfaitement conçu
avec tout pour s'auto gérer se régénérer
se réinventer
plus vous allez remmener votre attention
ici dans l'instant présent plus la paix
d'esprit voit s'installer dans votre
machine plus la paix d'esprit va
s'installer dans votre machine parcours
effet plus la clarté va s'installer et
plus la clarté et la paix d'esprit va
s'installer plus la reconnexion avec qui
vous êtes vraiment va s'installer
vous méritez ce que de meilleurs dans la
vie vous devez être vigilant par rapport
aux discours et heures que vous avez sur
vous à chaque instant je serai pas là
autant j'y arriverais jamais les eaux
son tout meilleur que moi au uk doit
accueiller ce qui est là mais je dois
prendre conscience que la responsabilité
de changer ce disque aux intérieurs là
ma partie et pour ça j'ai besoin de
reprendre la maîtrise de mon attention
revenir au moment présent rétabli la
paix d'esprit et choisir des pensées qui
vont être alignés avec mes rêves avec
mes projets avec mes convictions
profondes
tout est déjà là l'intérieur de vous
jouer ses dépenses et bio apprenez à
vivre en cohérence avec vos valeurs en
cohérence avec cette grande vérité
universelle et surtout en cohérence avec
vos convictions profondes merci tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]